hello everyone I'm Milan and welcome to
another episode of good gaming news
which is a weekly show where I talk to
you about all of the good gaming news
that has happened open announced this
week rather than focusing on the bad
because there is a lot of bad it can be
worthwhile to focus on I'm just trying
not to add to that fire and instead give
you something positive first up we have
a story uh from CD proyek Reds Twitter
Mission outside of the Twitter from what
I can tell but it is very positive and I
love the transparency so uh this is the
CD project red IR account which is
specifically their investor relations
account I don't know how many Publishers
have these but I think it's a great idea
so we have
long-term product outlook here which
lists The Witcher
as the series with Sirius here by the
Molasses Flood a new Witcher Trilogy by
CD projekt Red and Canis Majoris by
third party which we will get into a
little bit further for cyberpunk 2077 we
have Phantom Liberty which we obviously
already know a little bit about which is
the cyberpunk 2077 expansion by CD
project red and Orion which is a whole
new game also by CD project
and then a new IP and I guess a game
called Heda we don't know exactly what
that is yet uh realistically all three
of these are code names so let's dive in
a little further shall we first up again
the one we kind of already know a little
bit about is cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty which is a major story driven
expansion to cyberpunk 2077. it is in
final production stage right now which
to be clear
that can take years and is developed by
the CD program team which is currently
350 plus people I didn't even know that
next up is Project Sirius which we don't
know much about at all this is an
Innovative Take On The Witcher Universe
telling an unforgettable story for
existing Watcher fans and new audiences
apparently this is developed by the
Molasses Flood supported by CD project
red and I believe I'm not super familiar
with them the Molasses Flood has
released two games previously the flame
in the flood and Drake Hollow both of
which have this like really specific
sort of art style you can see here the
flame in the flood is a rogue-like river
journey through the back Waters of a
forgotten post societal America
looks cool and has very positive uh
reviews on Steam actually the average is
mostly positive 75 of the 2000 plus user
reviews for this game are positive
there's plenty to Love in This heartfelt
Survival game
an absorbing game that lets you
experience a journey
it's like
hello everyone welcome to my channel
where I will let you experience a video
we have veterans from the Bioshock Halo
guitar and Rock Band series apparently
there you go the other game is Drake
Hollow which is also a survival game
um they're a little bit different in
style but I think this is probably sort
of what we can expect their art style is
consistent across these two games oh
that's cool Hello Sunset Overdrive this
one has recent mixed reviews largely
mostly positive less reviews overall and
was published by CD predict already so I
feel like this is probably what you can
expect from this project
um serious as it is is probably going to
be a survival game with a similar art
style to Drake Hollow and the flame in
the flood next one is Project Polaris
which is a story driven open world RPG
built on the legacy of the widget 3 wild
Hunt this one is being developed by CD
preak dread and is currently in
pre-production it is the beginning of a
new Witcher Trilogy in all three games
are aimed to be delivered within a six
year period following the Polaris
release which is pretty nuts to be
honest how have I did see people like
even on the dev team tweet some kind of
jokey stuff that's like if you know
anything about us you know that that
might not end up happening
I think we can probably expect some
delays but they did say aimed to be
delivered so maybe that is the current
pre-production goal I would be shocked
if they can pull that off with the size
of that team godspeed CD project
godspeed good luck next is Canis Majoris
which is a story driven single player
open world RPG set within the Witcher
Universe contracted to be developed by a
third party Studio led by ex-witcher
veterans
which is an interesting one
I wonder what this is and how it differs
from the mainline Trilogy and why don't
know would really like to have more
information about that one project Orion
is the cyberpunk 2077 sequel that will
prove the full power and potential of
the cyberpunk Universe I hope that
that's the case would take two my
friends I mean really if anything you'd
hope that they've learned lessons from
what happened with the launch of
cyberpunk 2077 which I feel is basically
inevitable it hurt their stocks that
means that the business people have to
take notice that's just how it works
reviews and internet outrage are one
thing and of course they hurt the dev
team that people working on the game get
really upset by that it is personally
probably extremely stressful to deal
with but the thing that actually makes
the Publishers take note which are the
people who basically Force the dev team
to release the game early the publishing
side the business people is the stock
market CD proact Reds stocks diving
after cyberpunk 2077 was released is
like one of the best thing that could
have happened for basically like the
whole industry to come out of that
circumstance it's very good for gamers
because it actually gives other
Publishers more of a reason to listen to
their Dev teams now devs get to go okay
but the stocks actually did go down this
look at how this actually did affect
their business because businesses are
always going to be like I don't care
about you stupid tweets or your angry
YouTube videos the stock market what
it's great news and I I can't imagine
they'll make the same mistake again but
I suppose we'll see and then the third
one is expanding with a third IP project
hater new Standalone IP distinct from
The Witcher and cyberpunk 2077 this one
is developed 100 internally IP
incubation since late 2021 so it's very
new currently in the conceptual phase by
a small Strike Team so we're not even in
pre-production yet and there are some
people in the Tweet replies here saying
things like You're communicating too
much you could just do this sale at the
end of the radar I we prefer that they'd
be candid about uh what's going on
within the studio I am very much in
favor of it and this would be their
first time working on a new IP which
could be really exciting next up some
cool news regarding a game that I'm very
excited about the Kalisto protocols AI
is more interested in scaring you than
killing you apparently and I am on board
this is from vg24.com and uh it's a
Striking Distance wants to kill you sure
but according to striking distances CTO
Mark James it'd much rather scare you to
death than bludgeon you I just I'm very
into this concept conceptually I'm
interested the article says the Callisto
protocol gets constantly compared to
dead space and it makes sense really a
lot of developers are the same a lot of
the core ideas are the same and it even
looks quite similar really it's two
comma reallys your editor should have
taken out but this new Venture from
Young developers Striking Distance is
doing more with its horror than Dead
Space could back in 2008 where 14 years
down the line now and technology has
come a long way Striking Distance really
cares about horror the staff have been
ruthless in studying the psychology of
fear and have boiled down the tenets of
human dread to how we respond to
Atmosphere attention brutality
helplessness and Humanity taking each of
these five strands and tinkering with
them individually Striking Distance
reckons it's made one of the scariest
games ever made oh my god let's go no
matter what your own tolerance for
horror is this is so cool like the idea
that they've
actually been like what makes man scared
tell me video games on ought now Boomers
instead of just being like we could make
that scary by maybe making it like a
little bit darker maybe add some sound
design to that they went right in for
atmosphere attention brutality
helplessness and Humanity that's cool
and I'm pumped why is the developer so
confident a lot of it comes down to Tech
Mark James Chief technical officer at
the studio tells me in an interview that
New Gen games can do things that just
weren't possible even a few years ago
while 50 of horror is in audio James
assures me that a large portion of the
Callisto protocol's dread comes from its
frankly sadistic AI I shouldn't be
pulling the space why am I so enthused
we have amazing AI our AI will sometimes
make the decision not to attack you it
will instead jump into a vent in front
of you making sure you see it happen so
you know that an enemy is in there and
it's just waiting for the next time it
can pop out of another vent and attack
you this is the alien isolation 2 that
we've all been waiting for previously
James had told me that the whole game
has a full vent system for its creatures
to come in and to go out of you might
return to a corridor and you see a
discarded vent crate on the ground and
then you see a hole in the ceiling hole
in the ceiling again another just added
this note quick editor's note for you
there vg24.com you're left with this
uneasy sense that something has been
there but you don't know what or indeed
where it is now it's the open door of
horror troops right grins James I didn't
open that door what opened that door it
makes you question that you're not alone
it's a very simple change in the
environment that makes the play a
question what's going on and that's very
powerful this sounds cool goes on to say
the AI is always finding the best way to
attack sometimes that's them trying to
get close to you sometimes they're
reacting to the way they're playing to
better take advantage of you say for
example you keep using long-range
ballistics the enemy will move out of
your line of sight probably into event
and find another way to come to you so I
have to keep using the grip then complex
grab gun but a little weaker and bring
enemies towards you to bash them with
your stun baton they'll get wise to it
they'll block and counter or they'll
make themselves more of a threat at
close range so you don't want them
anywhere near you that's very cool so
yeah I'm just very excited about this um
really really looking forward to this
game
and just another fun tidbit our next
story is going to be a really quick one
but always one that we want to shout out
which is no man's Sky Creator is happy
to leave micro transactions out of the
game
and I do really like talking positively
about no man's Sky because it had a
really rough launch I really did not
like the game on launch and now I love
no man's Sky I think it's fantastic glad
to see it win
um some basically like comeback type
Awards and the game is just about to
come out on Nintendo switch or it will
be by the time this video is up probably
and nintendolife.com sat down with game
creator Sean Murray to talk about All
Things No Man's sky and Nintendo live
said with the title expanding to normal
platforms it would make sense if hello
games were to change its business model
to move with the times and include other
revenue streams it seems so ever that we
can rest easy on this one asked if its
shift is a reasonable Prospect Murray
put us to see put us at ease with the
following response lots of people tell
us that there is this alternative
business model or that alternative
business model and there probably is but
we're enjoying this right now we really
enjoy working on the game and we have
got this really positive welcoming
community that I really get a buzz out
of making updates for and continuing to
tend to that game and I mean this seems
pretty legit it's probably really naive
which yeah they could probably make a
ton of money off of like
microtransactions for ships and stuff
but it's what we're doing and there's
historical reasons why we got into it
more purposeful reasons why we really
think that it's the right model for us
at the moment so like I said a very uh
short update there just wanted to give
them a shout out thank you hello games
we appreciate you next up this is on
games industry.biz Bandai Namco said at
Elden ring it's just the beginning
European CEO arnard Muller on the
Publishers growing Japan portfolio IP
creation and staying platform agnostic
in the face of consolidation
the article says for a few years now
conversations on this very site about
Bandai Namco have been revolving around
the company's desire to crack the West
Via its European Branch its strategy to
focus on uip and to work with the
biggest independent Studios this year
our conversation with Bandai Namco
Europe CEO on Nord Muller at Gamescom
felt like all of this was now coming
together underlined by the massive
success across Western markets of Elden
ring the from software developed hit is
currently 2022's best-selling title
across Europe ahead of FIFA 22. what oh
Pokemon Legends Arceus
as of June 2022 it had sold 16.6 million
units globally at its Bandai namco's
fastest selling game of all time dude
you love to see it yes when asking
Muller what the success of Elder ring
means with Bandai Namco and whether the
Publishers Western Ambitions have now
been achieved the answer is level headed
it's a global success but it's not our
first Global success he smiles pointing
to Tekken among many other successful
Bandai Namco properties the difference
with Tekken is that eldering succeeded
in a genre sounds like that's previously
been less mainstream and falls into the
category of new IP a topic close to
Bandai namco's heart having invested 96
million pounds into its IP access
strategy this year which is
so cool if you haven't already heard
that story from earlier in the year that
does come with a slight caveat that part
of that is like metaverse related but I
don't know that it will be like the nft
web 3 Facebook metaverse type related
basically they want to create a virtual
space where like a bunch of their IP can
live together and they need more IP to
be able to do that and make it make
sense so axis as a thing slightly less
into caring about new IP as a means for
that fine do it make new IP
it goes on to say we're extremely proud
of Elden ring and the latest number is
16.5 million sales in quite a short
period of time while it continues but
very proud of the quality of the game
we're very happy with the relationship
with from software well then ring too I
mean there's no way that Elder ring
doesn't get a sequel It's just it's
it just printed money it just it kept
vomiting money and it it hasn't stopped
yet again it took Dark Souls 3 over four
years to sell 10 million there is no way
that there isn't an Elden ring too it
just it too much money which I'm happy
about we worked with from software on
the Dark Souls series but Elder ring is
taking the genre to a new level the open
world the accessibility of the game the
depth it clearly has to pass out
expectations and also fans expectations
it's a great success I think we
anticipated the game was going to be a
very high quality game but the fact that
it touched such a large audience is
extremely pleasing and we're very happy
I mean no [ __ ]
of course you are so there's a little
bit more detail about some of the other
games that they have right now that work
with supermassive on the dark pictures
Anthology series and even though
supermassive got acquired uh they still
have a partnership with Bandai Namco
which is cool so yeah there's a little
bit more
um detail here if you want to look up
this article Again Games industry dub is
it's called Bandai Namco Elder it's just
the beginning the only other thing that
I really wanted to mention from this
article is that from a band Dynamic
perspective we've always been platform
agnostic we will remain platform
agnostic so I believe they were asked a
question um regarding acquisition and if
they have any interest in being
purchased and the answer seems to be no
and that to me seems like good news we
want our IPS and our games to be
accessible to as many players as
possible whatever they're playing on and
that goes to mobile as well which I am
not against Bandai Namco I think has
always wanted to be platform agnostic
because it doesn't matter on which
platform people play on we love to hear
it okay two really short stories to
finish this off one steam deck is now
available without a reservation order
one you can have it shipped to you so if
you've been meaning to get one
steamtech.com you can just grab a steam
deck now you can also order the steam
deck docking station which is the
official Dock and USB hub now which
allows you to plug it into more displays
peripherals power and wired networking
than any reasonable person should
they've also shipped software updates
focused on giving you more control when
docked to an external monitor faster and
more responsive typing on the on-screen
keyboard and a rollouts are continuing
to Japan South Korea Taiwan and Hong
Kong so there's also a reservations
available for
those regions and then I guess they got
a couple more questions about doc specs
so for some dot specs we have
multi-stream transport enabling
multi-moditor support DisplayPort 1.4
plus HDMI supports up to 1440p 120hz or
4K 60hz freesync support easy firmware
updates via steam deck and 45 Watts type
c power supply it looks pretty nifty
it's a nice little
dock there so that's cool last but not
least hello everybody my name's Alana
Pierce and I really love Neo automata
the game is officially out on Nintendo
switch and if you haven't played it you
should and first let me say
anybody who tells you but you have to
finish the same game 10 times it's a
liar you do not have to do that
near automata does have multiple endings
but not like one of them's just you died
at this point and it's like a joke
ending majority of them are like fake
out joke endings right and the idea of
having to repeat the game is actually
you play through the game once but the
first half is from two different
perspectives and that's like one of the
best things about it it is it sucks that
it's spoken about like a negative it's
such smart storytelling in my opinion
and then the second half of the game is
from a completely different perspective
but yeah it's just don't let them don't
let don't believe the lies it's so good
and I also just thought that this was a
really fun article from Square Enix yeah
I'll tell by the end of your heart
Edition is out now on Nintendo switch
but what's included in this portable
version of the game we can answer some
questions written by Duncan Heaney on
Square Enix games.com this is just a
really again a really fun article I've
like never seen Square do anything like
this maybe I haven't been paying enough
attention they said this will probably
be the easiest article I ever write
their automata is out now on Nintendo
switch it's a true Masterpiece and you
should buy it and there we go job wait
you say that's not enough what do you
mean I should address some common
questions about the game and provide
useful details Psy fine what is nir
automata the end of yoha Edition you
probably already know that near automata
is a very good action RPG that features
exciting combat Innovative mechanics and
a moving thought-provoking story here on
top of the end of your heart Edition is
a very good action RPG that features
exciting combat Innovative mechanics and
a moving thought-provoking story on
Nintendo switch it does also include DLC
and free items to download so wait
you're telling me that ner automata is
now portable yup being on Nintendo's
hybrid platform means that you can play
the game both docked and portable
whichever way you play The Game's been
optimized to provide a great experience
can I play it on the bus sure can I play
it on the toilet I mean if you want no
judgment here maybe in the bath well not
if it's plugged in that would be very
foolish plus it seems like a lot of risk
of water damage to your switch so I
wouldn't recommend it but technically
yes in a dark room while contemplating
the quiet futility of existence ah I see
you played a near game before and then
they just go on to tell you why the game
is awesome and they're right it's really
good but yeah I mostly just wanted to
highlight this because it's a really
really fun article here's um some info
about what's actually included and I
don't know it's like nice to just see
Square having some fun it's the fun
thing to read that suits the the tone of
I feel like platinum and like yokotaro
and the studio in general if you haven't
played Nia you should play it it's on
switch it's wonderful and that is it for
me this week everybody I will see you
guys next time bye